In the US, the thumbs-up sign means "well done,..."
...or is commonly used by hitchhikers.
But don't use it in Greece, Russia, Sardinia or West Africa...
...because you'll be insulting the recipient with a hearty "up yours."
Be careful with this.
In the US, this sign means everything is hunky-dory.
But in Russia, Brazil, Turkey and the Mediterranean,...
...it means something very different,...
...something along the lines of, "You are a homosexual."
In France and Belgium, it means the recipient is a worthless zero.
If you're in Greece, don't tell someone to stop by also holding up your hand...
...palm out in all five fingers at attention...
...you'd be telling them to go straight to hell.
Jenna Bush was televised flashing this symbol in Norway...
...to show her pride for Texas,...
...not realizing that she was inadvertently telling the entire Mediterranean...
...that their spouses were being unfaithful.
The sign means "cuckold" and is popular in Spain, Portugal, Greece, Colombia,...
...Brazil, Albania and Slovakia.
If you go to the Philippines, whatever you do don't tell someone to "come here..."
...by curling your finger forward and motioning repeatedly...
...unless you want to get arrested.
It's considered to be a gesture befitting only usage on a dog...
...and is punishable with jail time if used on a person.
Placing both hands out, palms down, fingers outstretched to settle a crowd...
...or to tell people to wait is commonplace in the US.
So be careful using those seven hand gestures abroad.